welcome back to CBS this morning the
Democrats in last night's CBS News
debate held almost nothing back in their
last confrontation before Saturday's
South Carolina primary and next week's
Super Tuesday candidates desperate to
stop frontrunner Bernie Sanders momentum
took him on from start to finish
Medicare for all will lower health care
costs in this country by 450 billion
dollars a year the math does not add up
it adds up to four more years of donald
trump doesn't show enough about how
we're going to pay for it I dug in I did
the work and then Bernie's team trashed
me for it former New York City Mayor
Mike Bloomberg hit Sanders over
intelligence claims that Russians are
trying to help him in the election
Vladimir Putin thinks that Donald Trump
is should be present United States and
that's why Russia is helping you get all
the ules
him if I'm president the United States
trust me you're not going to interfere
in any more American elections a CBS
News poll taken after the debate shows
47% of viewers came away feeling nervous
about the available candidates while 42
percent were optimistic 45 percent they
were said they were impressed by Sanders
performance that's the largest number
for any candidate senior political
analyst and 60 minutes correspondent
that's John Dickerson is here along with
CBS news political contributor and
Democratic strategist that's Joel Payne
join us at the table to discuss last
night it was a raucous not as that you
keep your answers to a minute and 50 I'm
gonna start with you because Bernie
Sanders entered the debate as a
front-runner after last night's
performance does he remain in that
position do you think I think so they
all discovered he was the front-runner
in a way and it felt like yeah the
biggest bullseye on his back did and it
felt like one of those disaster films
were somebody rummages through the
drawer throwing anything at that mean
they went I had him on guns electability
effectiveness and that was part of the
problem is that it was a diffuse kind of
yelling at Bernie Sanders and so he was
able to stand there and carries on
nobody was able to really prosecute the
case against Bernie Sanders and if you
don't do that
he's marching forward and if you're
unable to stop him then it's a good
night for him even though in the
aggregate it was a it was a night full
of kind of messiness for democrat joel
buddha judge made the argument that a
Sanders nomination would be a drag on
the rest of the ticket possibly cost the
Democrats Congress did he make his case
in that argument sure Buddha judge is
always very eloquent on nights like this
the problem is is that we haven't seen
these debates be real game changers you
know Elizabeth Warren certainly had a
nice debate last week but you know did
it really carry her to any success in
Nevada not not really
and so these debates while in the past
maybe in previous cycles they've been
game changers they haven't been this
cycle I think people were looking for a
moment that's why you noticed it felt
like a rugby scrum until you got I'm
sure you still have your flap jacket on
from last night but I'm not sure if
anything changed fundamentally about the
race I do think that Joe Biden had some
good moments and probably was able to
maybe help run up the score a little bit
in South Carolina he needs a big victory
a small modest victory in South Carolina
really does him no good he needs a ten
point plus victory something like that
to really change history in the race we
had been slipping in the polls among
black voters a majority electorate there
in a Democratic primary you think he
wants some of those back I think
potentially even you look at that moment
with Tom Steyer where he went after him
on private prisons it's clear that he
was going after some of that vote that
steyr has siphoned away from him over
the last couple of months if he can pull
three or four percent from steyr maybe
he can pad those numbers a bit Elizabeth
Warren with with with Bloomberg she has
an instinct for the jugular right she
was going after with Bernie Sanders she
has an instinct for the capillaries
which is to say to me he is the
front-runner she needs to go after him
and she made a very interesting case at
the beginning which is we believe the
same stuff but I'm so much more
effective and it's gonna get done if I
get in office that's the lane for her to
make the case you must stop this person
because he's even if he gets an office
he's not gonna deliver but she made the
case and then moved on and then walloped
Bloomberg again and again I suppose the
conclusion she's drawn is let me show my
stuff rather than articulating a case
against Sanders and just hold people
like me always like your visual
analogies or the capillaries biology
class but let's talk about Bloomberg for
a second because he
by his own admission it was not as
finest hour that last debate did he
redeem himself last night
well not when you asked him the question
about and stop-and-frisk I mean Pete
Buddha judge gave the best answer by the
way in a stage full of white people
which about the lived experience of
being an African American and when you
ask Bloomberg about what he learned he
sort of gave a tactical answer it seems
to me that what he did a little bit of
this but the argument for Bloomberg is
you're not gonna like a lot of things
about me but here's the deal you care
about X Y & Z I've run big things I've
been in a pinch if you look at the
coronavirus it's a challenge for a
president in two ways one you have to
believe in a system that sets up the
American government to handle these
things and then when the bad stuff
happens you have to be able to manage it
and Bloomberg's argument is I've done
that I've been tested and you can't come
into this job if you haven't been tested
that's his argument he should have given
it to every question he was asked he
didn't he was all over the place if you
look at the poll at the end of this
debate which shows that people were most
impressed it seems by Bernie Sanders
then basically that says that all these
other candidates failed last night sure
I mean you could say you could say that
again nothing really changed about the
race I do think that folks were starting
to also look past South Carolina to
Super Tuesday
I know Amy Klobuchar I talked a little
bit about Texas she's expecting to do
well in Minnesota and Colorado I think
it's interesting to outside of the
debate Bernie Sanders is making buys in
Massachusetts Minnesota he's really he's
not in party unification mode he's still
in very aggressive on his heels try or
not on his heels on his on his tippy
toes trying to attack trying to take out
Elizabeth Warren trying to take out Amy
Klobuchar so he has not decided to bring
the party together yet he's still
deciding I want to go after people and I
want to be on the attack as an
anti-establishment candidate all the
attacks against him validated his
underlying argument which yeah
John Dickerson Joel Payne thank you both
for being with us